(coughing)
- I can't smoke the bongs,
dude, I'm too old for bongs.
Okay, so we have the same exact
deck,
in the same exact order, so
your top two cards should be,
10 of clovers and king of black
tears.
- I have clubs.
- I guess you say clubs, I
say clovers, tomato, tomato.
- And then a king of
black tears, what's that?
You mean the spade?
- What's a spade?
- A spade like it's like the
shape.
- Yeah it looks like a black
tear,
or a Hershey Kiss fucking
somebody's nose.
- That is weirdly accurate.
- Let's deal it out, baby.
Okay, I hope we did it right.
Do you have the king of black
tears and I have the jokers?
- I took all the jokers out of
my deck,
that's just a rule in my family,
because those are like wild,
and no I have the 10 of clubs.
- What's clubs?
- Clovers.
- Right. Tomato tomato, again.
- Toma'o toma'o.
Wait who's this?
Tomato.
- Tim Curry?
- Nanny McPhee.
- Oh, Nanny McPhee, yeah.
- Can we just like play
solitaire individually
and just talk?
- I really can only play
solitaire online.
- Oh because of the like--
the cards go nuts!
- Yes! The cards are like
Cumming.
You know what I mean?
- It's the most--
Satisfying thing.
- They're like,
- Just jizzing out
- Yes.
You just actin' out like what
that makes you feel like?
- Don't be mad, dude, but I
just,
I'm just sitting here with my
vibrator.
I'm not vibrating, it's not
inserted.
- We've had this conversation
before,
about how I would like to
know when that was going on.
- I'm not building up to
something,
this does not have a narrative
to it.
It's the same as if I had a
heating pad.
- I have a heating pad on the
small of my back right now.
- Well you're also a pervert.
- I think we need a second
to think about this.
- Okay I'm really sorry
I betrayed your trust.
- It's all right, I'll text
you in like a little bit.
- I hope your not mad at me.
All right, bye.
- Bye McPhee.
(vibrating)